okay we are back
live
oops we're going to do some stuff for
NYU real quick I got other client stuff
to deal with
today but
um we're going to deal with the stuff
for GPU Drive first I
think the client stuff will have the
whole rest of the week I actually do
have Friday as well this week so we
should be good
um so we've got curves here apparently
something's broken
with my the thing that I did for them
not really broken with that as much as
it looks like broken with
logging uh I think we're going to do
we're going to start here this will be
cool this will be cool work
do I think the way we're going to do
this is let me
see so we'll go to here
merge fix the
puffer and then we're going to
have
safe way
yeah this is
fine just making sure this doesn't undo
um my
stuff okay this is value function
Shenanigans is fine
is this is
fine so we make this PR
oh wait this is I got to use their
container right
image GPU drive but this is created 4
months
ago I was on my
local where's my
uh did I did I put this on the cluster I
don't think I
there we
go okay I was being dumb
now we got our
container go
fix we'll
keep keep theirs for now
OB okay so this is
reverted but this should not be reverted
so what we should do here is we keep
this and then get
OBS contr the agent mask like
yeah okay
so this should be good
dude what the [ __ ] this is not what I
wanted to do into to fix the
I I don't understand why the hell it
does
this this is going to push to this
freaking
that's so bad that it literally gives
you the wrong freaking
instructions it literally does the uh it
literally tries to make you do your
merge backwards so that you [ __ ] up the
branch that you're trying to emerge from
it's so stupid
it's like while in our terminology this
is like no it's
wrong I've actually done that before and
screwed up my
repo
command they do not have the train
command here
here it seems like it should be here but
it's not
see if this is
good yeah okay so this now
runs the params are slow
steps hang on how did this happen we
need their
hypers don't we need their hypers
I could assume that I'm just going to
solve it with our
experiments so let's see so they
got got all
500 oh they got they got rid of these
parameters
is it resample the
replacement res okay so these were
redundant cool so then they have some
time steps they've got
this 812 3 - 4 fals
95 five upd something's weird
here uh okay the because she sent me let
me had other parameters that she sent me
here were not as Terri those those are
real
bad
um we should be able to do a little
better and
this say
one
checkpoint
entropy
one MDA
gamma learning rate
is a little different
wait no it's the
same grad
Norm mini batch size okay that's the
weird
one and
then update epox
2 okay and then BF coefficient
04 flip this point to so this should be
good
and
I don't know where the hell this thing
is look for
it that
works oh
duh and I think they added back
drop
out see what you did
here yeah really
likes this
Dropout I can leave the Dropout though
because she doesn't use
it I think
oh no she does use
it
fine this she put the sharid in bed
back
something fine we we go back to this net
try to match then I'm going to I'm going
to fiddle with this app because I don't
think this net is
I probably just should take this whole
file to be
fair be better we'll be
uh how did
this l oh layers okay
online
puffer that's
let's see how this does sample with
replace how the
um ippo puffer Li should have gotten
this change
oh did I just delete a parameter that I
wasn't supposed
to yeah I just deleted a parameter I
wasn't supposed to
so yeah I deleted the wrong one so don't
need res exle Criterion you do need this
you do need this you do need
this
okay yeah the network is
slow the m is slow under this
faster than
before um but still very
slow so I should have um I should now be
able to go to my want
B I want be thank you
runs literally where are my projects
like where did everything go am you
stupid
uh
hello they just delete all my
oh there it
is okay yeah here we go
then 14 million or
so starts to do
something c%
continuously okay so this is not
working which is
weird
um trying to think what I could have set
up different here
somewhere
okay here's what we'll
we're going to just look at the diff on
on
GitHub container is really obnoxious
hold on actually let's do where's the
um well these are not the
same the
hell oh okay so there is a
diff let's
see fix the puffer let's see what I
changed here okay so I added this sweep
B let me make sure this is actually
getting
set it's not uploading the config
that's
sketchy it's very
sketchy oh
here it is
uploading ah this is
uh yeah this is screwing with our our
hyper parameters
we'll run
this and uh we
will continue checking this
diff
so move this up to
[Music]
here
there set experiment
that sweep runs
it's all
fine so the sweep mode is
fixed just examples so this is different
data
sets uh so we should probably check on
that that could be causing
this okay I would sent these parameters
so these are
good lat di I probably adjust this
yeah this might just do it it might have
just been the hyper Fram
stuff cuz I mean other than
that think there's anything here that
uh be too
fine and then there's all my uh these
modifications
I'm pretty confident in
these okay this is all I had
changed oh there we go look at
that no no longer
Offroad goal achieved is still low but
maybe this goes up after it goes Offroad
it justes stops going
Offroad we will watch
this want B
I'm going to go use the restro while
this uh does things and hopefully this
uh this trange so I'll be right
right8 not training as
quickly as I would
like I mean this isn't
where did the the other window I had to
go oh here it
is okay so they actually they very
quickly get
uh oh no there we go we're going up now
yeah yeah we were going up we got stuck
for a second but we're going
up one B needs to refresh
more it's kind of
ridiculous
what perk goal
achieved I'm literally seeing this being
higher than it's showing me what's going
on one bit
you I'm literally watching it did the
internet
die
no 83 I what's going
on there we
go it just takes forever I guess
so it was literally just um I think it
was literally just the logging that was
screwy with
this that's literally all that
was I mean that
was that's as expected
right let's go check the
Ral but yeah this is uh this is fine we
we
win puffer wins again
buffer
wins let me see we got this yep it's
going to spawn perfect
so next thing here will
[Music]
Pai thought there was an eval file in
here
92 we'll just wait till it gets an extra
checkpoint
here we'll be
good what are you up to fixing GPU Drive
um they couldn't get it to work with my
changes but it was literally it looks
like it was just a logging screw up so
I'm merging some stuff together and
fixing things for them real quick yeah
goal I'm just as soon as this number
goes up we'll have another checkpoint
we'll be able to eval this I don't know
how to run their script is the only
N just need one more check
point let's see if I can figure out what
they are doing
here
St all right so this will be easy as
soon as I figure out
how they are loading the
none
policy yeah I don't know how they load
policy here this is weird unless I got
the wrong
code hang on did I get the wrong
code doesn't look like there's anything
in here
now
where where they set the
okay their structure is way too complex
all right there we
worlds torch doesn't take n
worlds uh it looks like they gave me
like half of
a half of an eval script
okay I got to
reply give it a
[Music]
second
model config has
all your
models do that
then after this we get to actually make
it fast which will be
fun solving GPU drive at
250k for second
ideally if I just get the eval script
going I can
do the rest of this should be pretty
straightforward you
know probably not even that hard to
throw carbs on
this carbs
did I need screw up and not merge their
config right
different okay so this is a completely
different
experiment okay so there this is a
totally different experiment
let's see what this is
so the
policy and then this fails in roll
out reset because it doesn't have the
argument so this is an N
dot reset that doesn't have the argument
this let's try this
to fix a few more things
probably grab the uh the
cashing the
cash almost there
once I have this working we should be
set hey
welcome
uh yeah so they have uh a
new masking
thing to see so they have live agent
mask live agent so we don't need this
anymore
because oh no we do
this okay let me see what the shapes of
these things
it's already going to give you K agent
mask that's already done
or
this and I think we do we just comment
this for
really they have to update this thing
don't
point so now we flattened the
mask is this not depressing for
you I mean I'm spending a few hours of
my time to massively
accelerate um a lab's large academic
project
and I know exactly what I'm
doing and it's not particularly
difficult so not
really it would be depressing if it took
me 10 times as long but it
doesn't really well the point where we
can just have Huffer you know within a
few hours
really making a difference on a lot of
projects I've worked with way worse code
than this as well this is actually like
pretty
decent okay so we got next OBS shape got
live agent
mask
some
ahuh this is perfectly
fine we just
on action
template okay and this actually gets
easier we no longer
need uh we no longer need this at
shape so that should be
fine and then you you step
works and then it attempts to render
which we're going to disable I'm
sure uh live agent
math oh wait yeah we don't
perfect why the heck is that the action
coming out of the policy
there what are we supposed to step this
with hold on
I don't know what's up with
that let me go back to
uh what are you what actions are you
supposed to give back hang on
Apparently that is intentional that is
the most insane action space I've ever
seen on an RL
environment um that needs to be a multi-
discreet that's
okay uh what is the what are the actions
that are supposed to go into this thing
again
that what's the action space 697
discreet
yeah I know I have no idea what it's
completely insane
I guess it's just like learning to use a
few of the actions or something because
this is like this is like crazy
holy hell okay whatever we'll add that
to the list of things to
fix I think after I clear like once I
finish a contract up and stuff I'm just
going to help them like fully rewrite uh
Port this just to a CA environment
and like fix all these things cuz this
is like crazy be way faster they'll be
way
happier um they won't be able to call it
GPU Drive they'll have to Rebrand it a
little bit
but yeah I have no idea it's insane
yeah we got to test our multi- discreet
stuff if we've been having issues with
that um does it work at the moment
multi- discreet for your
stuff are you currently training with
mul
discreete seems to work okay
good I mean flattening your action space
can help for very small action spaces
up the number of
aiming yeah no don't do 16x
something also 16 is kind of
weird it's not an odd number can it
shoot straight ahead
okay oh maybe you did zero and like I
don't know what you did radial or
something I don't
know
um what what's wrong here like what
what's the format the MS are supposed to
be in the
whatever we're just going to do like
this um
[Music]
still uh the actions are still that [ __ ]
I'm
fine that's mildly
annoying let me see
yeah so we're going to keep it this way
I
think um
fine whatever if I just do GPU Drive
stuff today as long as I
okay yeah yeah yeah so this
is what that
okay so they just asked me to solve a
thousand scenes easy
don't know what that means
Jason I don't know why temperature would
be relevant here
for YouTube Folks at the
moment this is nyu's GPU accelerated
driving Sim um I have a build that
accelerates their training by a factor
of 10 up to about a quarter million
steps per second uh we've had some
issues they've had some issues getting
it running with their logging and stuff
and I'm currently I'm fixing that I'm
going to get the hyper pram stuff set up
properly this time and uh I think I'm
going to just solve the Thousand scene
like thousand different driving uh scen
version of this for them so I really
just hand them something that's like
super easy and doesn't really leave them
any anything up to
chance cuz like there were a few
basically I handed them a thing that
needed a few logging improvements to
work um
and they didn't do that instead they
like they reverted all the changes to
something that they could get working
which is like okay fine you know it's a
bunch of new code you're not familiar
with it you don't think it works but it
it does work it's just that they didn't
have the loging correct um it's fine I'm
just going to fix this for them and then
it's going to be know
easy okay so the thing with this
controlled agent mask is
we're
already I think they should already be
masked right unless am I wrong
here let me
see yeah because when you get this past
back you don't get the controlled agent
mask so yeah you should only be
wrong ah no no no it is okay it is
actually this I am
wrong so this is actually kind of fine
for eval I
guess yeah yeah this is kind of fine for
eval hold on let's just let me make this
this thing work
no yeah you can give this the whole OBS
and then this will be a
size control old agent mask
let me try
this it's a little
tricky I think it should be fine like
yay po dumped
great why does it do that
uh still core dump
how is that
back
policy what's this evaluate policy
confused wait
what okay so we have this thing which is
roll
out and roll out does
that is it even call
this gives you already the controlled
version
gosh okay this is fine this
is data
no not Jack we do not like Jacks
here
out I mean it doesn't really do anything
in here that
this one corrupted file in the train
data
well I would not have figured that out
so good thing I asked
there's your Discord why isn't it
open I love when software doesn't
whoops
uh
missing I don't know which one is
missing to be
what's this supposed to do for
me
have goal achieved let's see how this
gets logged
the
heck okay there's I got a piece of code
so many freaking
bugs let's run this come
on this should not be as
difficult it should be very e so much
Goode
know so you got your controlled agent
mask bugged agent
Over Control the agents
peran be goals
achieved live agent
mask is
here this should be correct it looks
correct
is there any way I could be over
reporting
rate so you get the
infos done worlds controlled mask
mask and this is so obnoxious like how
right
it doesn't
improve I think I have a
me make sure that this is the right run
as
oh wait hold
on I'm only training on 100
all it's literally not
resampling so this goes to
true we 5 million
steps go to
it we'll start with 100 and then we'll
go up to like 200 or whatever
so
slow
up 18 gigs
mostly the world's in
Compares it's doing the weird logging
thing again but
achieved okay that's not true um I don't
know why this this is one point
just do this their logging is screwy is
what's
is this
here
goal achieved is
uh we give it some time I
guess it's sampling way more scenarios
so maybe it takes
longer you know
move some stuff
[Music]
around uh where did the goal achieved
one
let me use a restro real quick we'll see
if this
okay so it is training
taking a while but it is
training it's weird that it's learned
not to collide at all but it's uh taken
so long to get the
goal though this m does have the
tendency to like just shoot up it's like
um once it starts learning it kind of
figures it out very
only this just needs to run way faster
as
all and like I know how to make it fast
as well but
I gotta I have to get a baseline before
I can run the oblations on
let me see what pams they
[Music]
um maybe there is something weird about
having to have a few unique scenes at a
time or
whatever let see
so I think this is the one yeah I was
like this
one um
scenes this is
500 I should just match this
I'll let this run but I should just
match this so yeah I don't know why it's
sampling from so
few let's
see num worlds 500 worlds is awesome I
wish I could do
that so let's see maybe I can fit 200
frame train
params and we get resample
through every 2 million which I've
changed to
five resample data set
size I don't know why this is
okay so we're pretty much spot
see put this to 1,000 set this to 1,00
100 we'll run this
next once we get
a nice policy
here we're going to solve this
got it's funny how it tends to like rock
like this it's probably just bad hypers
though I bet you once we do uh better
hypers we uh we kind of just
win let's see
parameters sample data set good so you
know we can probably still do a little
better than this do a little faster than
this let's
uh let's let this run finish out
between your streaming breaks
okay
um I'm trying to think if I want to do
this
okay y got to run for a meeting um I
will be back on in a bit but in the
meantime I'm just going to keep running
a couple of these experiments get
something nicer looking you know in the
background while I'm meeting and doing
other stuff and uh we'll
resume basically to polish up the last
bit GPU drive maybe put them a hyper
parameter sweep in place maybe optimize
their throughput a little bit all that
good stuff will be uh once I'm back and
uh for folks watching if you are
interested in puffer lib and all this
fun RL stuff puffer doai you can play
all of our environments right on the
website you can watch the agents play
them uh we've got a Discord 900 people
doing all sorts of RL stuff join this if
you're interested in contributing using
puffer getting support whatever star the
repo helps me out a ton it's all open
source and if you're looking for more RL
content you can follow me on X got tons
of articles on stuff and uh post pretty
much exclusively RL content so